well thanks for coming out I'd love for
you to go around the room and introduce
yourself and tell me where you're from a
little bit about yourself but I'm able
to beauty I'm from Dallas okay working
on a modern business school modern
business school yes
sorry cool yes I see there's a lot of a
lot of things you talked about yeah I
believe in it yes so I wanted to make a
difference and change it so master class
it has normal people teaching the class
yep and focus on entrepreneurship and
mindset that's the first thing that we
work on that's the thing that I want to
work on teaching whatever looks like
amazing people that what were you doing
before had a we have a tobacco business
manufacturing tobacco hookah pipes and
hookah tobacco that we sell
internationally and that's a family
business we did it we've done that from
oh three and I left the day-to-day in
2015 and then started working on
something and that is like family as in
like assembling another my brother
started in his bedroom and then my whole
family got involved in o-5 so I left a
flight test engineering job at that
helicopter to then work there with him
and I was nuts
like totally did all that stuff and
successful landing 500 list and so forth
and then when I left in 2015 because I
wanted to do something different and
when I do the consulting and then I
realized like this isn't like a broad
impact and so I was focusing and when I
was working with people I realized like
mindset was of something that was really
beating up people and so I started
working that and then finally figured
out that I wanted to do this in school
so in the middle of Dallas massive
failure it's gonna be it's all line so
so live events but I did him I did a
mobile tech startup I totally crashed
that and so in that concept of
connectivity though was like well let me
still do that let me just be a real-life
version of that so the out was called
refer me and it was about connecting
people so it's really cool so then I
just bring those people and put them on
camera and I'm the backbone of the
platform for I understand very cool
thanks nice Todd books man hey Todd
father of three just had my 28th
anniversary here on Friday with my wife
Congrats where do you live
Phoenix Arizona you guys kisses good
timing you did it in New York
flew in a day early because they
canceled our flight the hens day so
caught the last flight out of Phoenix on
Tuesday night so we got lucky there and
we're a couple hats through start
coaching and mortgage industry in other
industries as well a couple years back
and developed a sales performance
product for loan officers and real
estate agents that's kind of my passion
now because I feel like I can impact
more through that product when I can
one-on-one and that's that's kind of
what I'm here to figure out how to
continue to grow that and scale it as we
move forward that's cool
some Gary mikail just I'm from Chicago I
run a company called national corporate
credit we raise money for startups small
businesses I started it with a buddy of
mine in 2008 right out of high school so
I didn't go to college and I've been
growing it ever since got a great timing
good timing yeah good timing so we've
been building it ever since
kind of been in the trenches doing deals
through a lot of JB's don't really have
much of an influence or standpoint just
yet but that's what I'm here to learn
okay yeah man it's good to be here I'm
glad you're here thanks Brian McCann met
you a couple months ago yep you did a
shout out to my sister who terminally
ill and my sister who doesn't complain
as my aunt would say it won't say [ __ ]
with him helpful she responds to your
video and she's not effusive man she
doesn't put it out
she does I'm gonna save it forever all
right say a lot more right to second
because of that yeah we'll come back
around
yeah appreciate it my man it means a lot
to me Chris clothier Miss Tennessee
married with a bob kids poof yeah you
guys aren't fooling around
yeah one of the ages sixteen twelve
eight six and three sixteen you had a
baby when you were three
you're a good man for a 16 year old he
was warming I was 30
so everybody look great yeah cool six
one more time sixteen sixteen twelve
eight six
oh wow nine six and three amazing she's
gonna get on me for that that's amazing
make good for you good we own a family
business Kate with my father and brother
father and as a real estate investment
firm okay my wife and I have a
charitable foundation yeah we run yep
one's called kids kicking cancer and
then the other one is charity water
thank you guys for the cherry water and
yeah having fun and yeah I saw somebody
yesterday I've only had one job for
someone else ever since I was 17 I've
worked at the family business or started
my own businesses very cool
so this is excited to be here awesome hi
Gary oh thanks Kristi ray I'm from sunny
Buffalo New York
I have a newborn side first longer yeah
foreign grass out she'll be 22 weeks
tomorrow so this was like the thing for
me to be here
uh-huh night flying and you know this
was like I get it cuz I'm like so spin
with the girl
I own the water filtration business and
you know with my dad and was pointing
his work he near kitchen contractors and
we wanted to sell a water filtration
product to our customers and we couldn't
find anything that we liked so we
actually made Italy developed our own
scratch an itch yeah and
we then start selling the product to
other key near finishing contractors or
plumbing contractors to let them sell to
their in a way it went
and it went and in the meantime was able
to get some some some celebrity
testimonials about it find that
interesting all all celebrities of
customers of ours that I didn't paid one
cent burning those testimonials
interesting nice I thought that that's
very cool and whenever you build the
best product you win yeah well my
business model is kind of flawed because
now I'm relying upon a plumber who's in
the house to sell the product while he's
in the customers house and - and it's
like a really tough business mama where
so what I'm looking to do is get some
ideas about how I can go direct to
consumer yeah I totally get it
thank you okay I'm Mitt Romney and I'm
originally from India I moved to the
u.s. in 2015 for college and I think in
the summer of last summer I saw your
video on snapchat about how you scared
about what people are going to do after
graduating yes
and that completely blew my mind I was
like I need to know who this guy is
yes and what is he about since then I've
been following you on every platform
possible and I want my seat over here
I'm aware competition yes I'm aware so
pretty much so it's pretty I'm not
established in any industry of course
I'm 22 yes
jumping from side also to side also
tasting yeah tasting everything well
initially when I get gonna get on any
Santos and I'm like oh I'm gonna make a
billion dollars of course woman I get a
fuss I the moment I gave my first order
I'm like this is it that's it I think
that's a good trait as long as it's
grounded with you're not gonna make a
million dollars you know you have to
balance optimism with practicality I
think everything I literally every idea
that runs through my head including the
two that have happened while I've been
listening to you guys I always think is
gonna be everything I think that's good
I think to your point and it was funny
to get to see your reaction after listen
to your story I've been talking a lot in
my content right now to 20 to 25 year
olds around tasting everybody's biggest
problem is I don't know what my passion
is or what I'm good at I'm like criminal
so taste like if you don't know what
your favorite food is taste it you
salmon eat broccoli eat sea urchin eat
burgers drink like and we don't have
that system in place and I think for you
know for the rest of us here that are a
little further along after 22 the thing
you realize is 20 to 30 s exactly when
you should do high risk because as we
start building families and other things
in life happen
those are we have to react to that that
puts us on defense and you know so I've
been really thinking a lot about you
know I'm it's funny I'm a kid who
started working literally the day I left
college like when I drove from Boston to
New York that night when I got to store
around 3 or 4 p.m. because I left in the
morning I actually worked for 3 hours a
Twilight because I always worked when I
was home so it wasn't like like it
wasn't symbolically just normal like I
got there for and like you don't go home
at 4:00 I just got the liquor stored for
with the traffic so I just I don't know
just literally literally park the car
gave a huge hug to one of my best
college friends who was taking a bus to
the city and he was on his way to life
and I literally just like helped
customers for next three hours until dad
was ready to go home and we just went
home
and from that day to now I've always
worked so I didn't do normally
ninety-nine out of a hundred times
everything you hear for me is advice
that I've done on myself so that's why
I'm so confident in it ironically one of
my favorite piece of advice right now is
something I did polar opposite of which
was because I found the meal that I
became addicted to very early but I've
come to realize that wasn't the case
from and isn't the case for most and I
just think it's practical to hustle at
this age try different things some of us
stumble upon it in an alteration of our
own business sometimes we just bounce
away from it I mean everybody's got
their own stories of it a young dude
like this like you know his business is
very conditioned to the market behaviors
so I'm sure he recognizes this is a good
era but it could get bad and so what am
I gonna do when it gets bad when you
know so there's a you know but it's
great that you're tasting and you should
think everything's gonna be a million
dollars what you want to do though is
not get caught in a couple ways number
one I think a lot of people get caught
on good
so where you could get caught is you
could actually make a hundred thousand
and that first year be like actually
this is on its way to a million but the
upside was only two hundred thousand
always that's a very sneaky one very
hard to dissect you know good for the
you know you know alteration of bat of
great you know like taking good over
great but you should feel comfortable in
your tasting you know what was the right
thank you late okay this is not gonna
work for me I gotta be walked in the
next thing I got I don't have to cry
nobody's gonna you know one thing I tell
people is you're never gonna know the
alternative you're never gonna know that
if you quit the day before the next day
was going to be the beginning of the
future you'll never know and that's how
I live like that's how I strategize like
the answer is it scary I'm convinced
that there are millions of people not
knowing there's 10,000 people running
around right now that we're literally
one day away from it clicking and they
went and got another job or went back to
business school or like that's real life
and nobody wants to be that pertussis
videos like [ __ ] am i that person that
would be devastated right that would be
devastating that's devastating to me
it's a function of something else it's a
function of humility and what your
aspirations are let me explain the
reason I'm was destined to win is the
process was the win I'd won before I
started I being an entrepreneur was it
so to me I never had to worry about that
because I never allowed the way I lived
my life and I mean expenses look if
you're willing to live in a studio
apartment with three roommates in a
ghetto neighborhood you forever could be
an entrepreneur people only talk about
the money making like I'm gonna make a
million I'm always thinking like I can
live on 10,000 that keeps you in the
game forever so so I think a lot of this
has to do with what one does you could
you could you have the luxury of time
right now you know hopefully you stay
healthy forever and like you you've got
18 years in front of you minimally with
modern medicine you got you know that's
a lot of [ __ ] time and I think the
only thing that can hurt you is what
hurts everybody at 22
your parents pressure your own pressure
on yourself
because you see your friends starting to
accomplish certain things what's that
good so to me I had psyche that was
crazy
I loved that at 26 some of my friends
were starting my good student friends
were starting to make money because they
went to a good school and I went to
Goldman Sachs and they were making money
and they were buying a BMW and a watch
and I [ __ ] loved it
because I wrote it motivated me in a
great way because I knew I knew who I
was and and the snarky comments and you
know now I'm garyvee to everybody let me
just tell you like just listen very
carefully I'm 26 and I work for my dad's
liquor store yeah like you got to really
understand where I was I I'm 26 and I'm
working for my dad's liquor store that's
this that's my brand amongst my circle
four years out of college like now
because I wasn't promoting that the
business was growing very rapidly you
know I you know attaching your own
happiness or sadness to somebody else's
actions is the quickest way to lose your
buddy making money has nothing to do
with you it just legitimately has
nothing to do with you your buddy making
money and getting pretty girls because
of it just legitimately has nothing to
do with you I understand that 22 you
want to hang out pretty I get it I
understand what people want in life I
understand the psyche of men women young
old it all makes sense it just doesn't
have anything to do with you and the
sooner you can get to that place I just
shut everything out because then you
could stay patient likes it
yeah but that's where people get caught
you know parents pressure or trying to
keep up with the Joneses outside forces
hey hey I'm Brooke what Brooke I am 24
years old and I design websites for
estheticians and begins industry for
vegetables very cool so it's a service
based business um you design on top of
platforms I just had a with Squarespace
because they like to manage their own
website make sense and it's an easy one
for them to manage exactly it's a great
platform I'm very friendly with the
founder of square I'm a big fan the only
thing I love their copper I'm addicted
to it yes you could take me off of it I
hate they really a program because I
would be great a limiter exactly but no
I just wanted to come here today because
it was literally I was thinking on the
walk here it was you live here you know
where do you live I live in San Diego
City hell yeah but I was just like a
year and a half ago so like summer of
2016
like I literally couldn't afford lunch
and I I dropped out of college three
times which was really hard because both
my parents were college professors
puts us apart it wasn't for me and Amy
sure you know when you were trying to
make them happy right I get it because
they're good people you know it's like
you don't do it I went I mean I'm the
most anti Catholic college pushing on
earth and I went to college for four
years because I love my parents and like
you know that's what they wanted so I'm
not I know it's funny I wasn't worried
about making I literally was checking
the box yeah like I wasn't trying to
excite the Mahina Kai which I was
checking a box for them Community
College 13 yeah yeah by the way now I
does below community college so like to
me to me to me you know it's funny I'm
such an optimist I actually haven't
thought about this in a long time
idle and I did say this to somebody
recently maybe you have this content
babban
I literally converted it into vacation I
viewed it as my last vacation I knew
that I was gonna be a workaholic cuz I
already was and I literally just
transformed my mind and said this is
gonna I didn't go to camp I didn't hang
out in high school or junior high cuz I
worked all the time I was like this is
just that's what I did anyway
nonetheless she dropped out three times
and then a year and a half ago you
couldn't afford a lunch and then and
then I started listening to your content
and it totally like you know just your
message of getting your act together do
the right thing work hard it was just
like duh you know so I started just
doing random I have always had like an
eye for design so I can random things
I've learned Photoshop literally through
YouTube videos that's exactly right
eight hours a day just like yeah and
then I would take on projects that I
knew I wasn't qualified for but I just
like learning
yes but now it's like it's turning to
assist figure based on today and so I'm
just like I just I thank you it's
awesome
you should thank yourself there's a lot
of people consuming my content you did
something with it it's cool thing I'm so
glad you're here and Niles from Chicago
there's a good vibe
I started in advertising when I was 21
and we just got fired on my birthday and
Mary gloss called an agency I was a
radio direct marketing Direct Mail we
could do the creative yellow that's up
and uh they see my box calling party you
know I went out the night before you
called the fired me remember that I'm
loved give me two days I've got a bunch
of leads I'm working let me come in and
show you that can closed yeah because I
have that I'm working come in the next
day and then ever since that day came
back literally close all those deals
stayed and advertising for probably a
good part of eight years it was topics
you know salesman twenty four months in
a row crossed all their records and all
three just started did you need that
push when you got fired I think I did
yeah I think I felt super interesting
yeah I think I probably did yep maybe it
was something I was looking for you know
it's funny I'm open the reason I asked
you that in a in a kind of like in a
thoughtful way of what was going through
my mind is I'm fascinated by talent I'm
fascinated by school like I'm just
fascinated that I did nothing for 12
years me makes no sense you know like
it's just kind of like if you're that
good of a salesman but you weren't
performing before it's interesting that
that's what was the trigger you know and
I think people get motivated by
different things like I don't I'm not
get motivated by negativity at all
firing like when clients like when
clients call even when I need it like my
whole life like even when I was tiny
like baseball card like as a kid
lemonade like if you do it like I'd go
the other way I'm not motivated by you
know and everyone's motivated by
different things and just like
understanding that is fascinating to me
I think it's predicated on talent like
when you have talent you're
subconsciously understanding things like
it doesn't make any sense to me that
what I'm about to tell you is true
no third grader should be sitting in
class
realizing this makes no sense and will
not impact my life you shouldn't have
that level of wisdom or thought like
that should not like I can't wrap my
head around that that's what I I
actually did that like who knows what
words I used I'd like to think they were
I assumed they were different words but
like so like the fact that you could
sell that well but weren't and
somebody's saying you're fired
then just was that was it it's cool and
interesting anyway nonetheless you know
too bad right show up yeah supposed to
be or not yeah you're done and you
finagled your way to 48 hours hung up is
past yeah call them back as like look I
get it you know you're right it's a
comfortable yes your birth yeah he's
right yeah anything I'm like look I got
I got a ton of leads of the system give
me two days if I can't close anything
I'm caught
ultimately I'm closing all those ended
up climbing the ropes all the way to man
it's so cool VP then mark oh sorry so
you're there for eight years and then
what did your own thing okay no they
launched a separate division on Scouts
that went there for two years it's
probably 2007-2008 and then ultimately
it was just nobody was working out there
you know there was no growth by the way
it's so funny I have the funniest point
of view on Arizona and San Diego its
address on his way but San Diego freaks
me out like I go there it freaks me out
I go there and all the entrepreneurs
there I'm like I'm like literally I
enter sit first of all it's the most I
don't know if anybody's been there it's
really the nicest place on earth it's
super nice and it's so chill it's so
like I feel like New York starting to
get even slow for me something like do I
need to move to China like like I'm like
looking for the action and San Diego
freaks me the [ __ ] I get there and I'm
like this you know like it's it's like I
know so many of my entrepreneurial
friends live there now cuz the lifestyle
is so great it's funny it's funny I'm
where I was going is actually compliment
anybody who's actually really working
hard in that environment really I give a
lot of credit to because it's just so
easy to get soft I get sucked into nice
weather like when I'm in LA like for
three days on biz
by the third day I'm like right I need
to get the [ __ ] out of here before this
tricks me you know I say it so basically
after that there's nothing going on
right yeah yeah I'm like such a boring
town amis yeah everything shut down
after ten o'clock and this is a delta
from Chicago right which i think is like
tier 2 by a landslide
good and then I send up just moving back
right it sold my shares and say you know
what it's time for me there's no burger
left yeah move it back and they launched
kind of a similar type of it makes
ecstasy for about two years you know was
getting a little bit of traction and
then one of my old buddies that I used
to work with was in real estate so he
ultimate said hey I've had a great idea
we can launch a brokerage I've got all
the way the leads work and all that so I
said let's give it a shot so we gave it
a shot and leave you know closing the
only I had for him going full force into
the real estate that you know partner
ended up not working out so ultimately
just had to pick up the pieces and we
drew the broker to about 40 45 agents
but our overhead was was like 20 25
grand a month it was just killing us
people are ordering stupid office
supplies what does [ __ ] like utilize
like what do we do we need to get a
clean house and basically just have to
find some rockstars be a boutique shop
so we did that over the years and all
that we now have about 14 15 agents but
all super seasoned able to kind of dummy
it down to more of like a true boutique
shop where you know you know you want to
work with a big shop you can but
definitely we're gonna give a better
service you know a more personal in Taj
excetera Trevor and I use all our
knowledge from the advertising world
we'll apply it to real estate because
the system was really broken I thought
in my opinion it's come you know 95
percent of the agents in my opinion are
incompetent and just honestly don't know
what they're doing so that later brought
me into launching the startup that I'm
working on now which is interesting
thing when your guys at worship gave you
pull them out of it you said in stock
dog [ __ ] or something like that and
whatever it's similar it's not
transaction management but it's more
data-driven so ultimately it's it's a
platform where it allows a broker not to
be incompetent or it has all of the data
and they're pre-loaded for them but it
also helps them with training
and it's a fast business meters yeah so
that's where I'm at now what I call it
business is still going great and third
stage of development with let's go home
right let's just took you a night when
we're here to hang out what's got a
question I want to tell you please know
I'm image Brian again distill Brian yep
figured I manage a real estate office
for Berkshire Hathaway broker manager
about sixty ages about forty live once
about three hours north of here and Gino
before he and Chris Stewart the ones
that cooked me up with that NFL thing we
were at and I had because Gino's way up
there on the evolutionary scale he asked
me if I leave here without telling you
this find another place I love it
he said he would have had you had
Boehner on board but year earlier as our
marketing firm and he said I had to put
the executive who was in charge of that
decision in my NFL I said what a say it
was not for long section and he said it
was a basic assume let him know it
wasn't a group decision this was a
mandate for me he said on a Sunday weeks
ago you got a big fan I know it I know
that yeah
I've been in business long enough to
know how this stuff works
you understand what I do for a living
always is not what people on defense
want to hear okay the most remarkable
part of vaynermedia and its success is I
haven't been selling anything anybody
wants yet
the most remarkable part of this company
you need to probably know this the best
coming from a little bit more of that
world vaynermedia is selling to a group
of people biggest companies in the world
Budweiser chase services and strategies
that nobody in upper management or
senior management or super senior
management believes in so the reason I
know that's the case is cuz I've spent
time with Geno and like he's an
entrepreneur right and he's like let's
talk about the 49ers and I talked about
the Jets and like and when we left there
I looked at one of my employees and said
we're gonna get this account and they're
like why do you think I'm like because
he's gonna force it that's exactly right
and I believe that he made the decision
he said this wasn't it yeah and that's
how things happen a veiner
like I let the team do tons of [ __ ] I
don't even know what's happened it's a
big company yeah but when I know
something's happening it's not gonna be
a group decision
I mean I'm gonna yeah if I'm involved
I'm gonna assess it and decide and and
and what I mean by that is if it's
something important that nobody else
would support and he sees the he sees
the light hundred percent yeah it's also
just he's smart you know you know I
always say I always like my life has
been super interesting over the last ten
years where other people have been
involved outside the customer like my
life is basically about the customer
like this is interesting with you this
is your business right now right like
the thought of being at the mercy of a
[ __ ] plumber is not interesting
not because it's a plumber and I'm
[ __ ] on a plumber or a realist agent
it's that you're dealing with somebody
else who has other financial vested
interest and ambitions if you got a
passive plumber who's wrapping it up
soon and is super happy with his or her
life like there's just not you know
doesn't care how much money they're
gonna make on the referral fee yeah
doesn't want to have the extra
conversation once I get home it says you
know and by the way you'll you'll enjoy
this and this is a little bit of a
curveball I don't need everybody to be
on fire like I think people can feel
like I'm motivational in the fact that
it's a manifestation of my optimism like
uh you know like I don't like that's why
I haven't built the business you're
building like I don't
need everybody to like I just want
people to be practical I'm super not
anything else it's why I've already made
if you pay attention like it's why I've
made a reference to you already of Alec
hey brother please make sure you're
paying attention every day to the
macroeconomic climate cuz that's your
vulnerability that's practical that's
I'm just practicing speaker like if you
really dissect me it's just about
staying alive and paying your bills like
and and doing it in a way that like if
you're gonna do that doing it in a way
where it's like fun to wake up in the
morning versus not but but but it's not
but I don't need everybody like for
example a lot of our businesses like you
know maybe they're not as scalable but
like camps afflicted me here's where it
gets to its basic form like you know
many people can build a six-figure
business a lot less than people think
so I hate there's a better you and I'm
glad you just made that actually you
just made my day like yeah you maybe
even even react this way and maybe if
I'm like I don't I think that especially
if you're under 25 right now this notion
that everybody has to like the fact that
almost every entrepreneur right now
under 30 thinks that a million dollar
revenue business is like where it starts
right like like this thought of like I'm
gonna build a trillion like wait why you
got caught is you entered the land of
trillion dollar businesses like you're
not building the next Instagram you're
not building they like but if you don't
get it like there's like 18 of them and
everybody's like I'm looking now hard it
is to build a consumer app yeah I know
you know now you know how expensive how
hard I how'd you know you know people
are raising thirty forty million dollars
in capital and failing with ease because
it's hard and so and so like I want to
start champagne like I think it's
remarkable to be able to do something
you like have a six-figure business
because I know you can have an
incredible life on that like the average
median income in America is fifty one
thousand forty seven two what's the
number you know the bottom of the
one-percent wealth in our country the
richest country in the world maybe China
I don't know but like [ __ ] we're in
there right
the bottom of it it's 400 something
thousand a year like if you make four
hundred thousand a year and up
you're the 1% the 1% of America but the
talk and the branding of
entrepreneurship and business is like 28
million I mean look it's so crazy
so I'm obsessed with practicality you
know like if you you know that's what I
like I like I like that a lot
so unfortunate you're the only one
saying that you see everywhere whether
it's oh I know no matter what it is
every ad is about the car you did it
right I mean how do you get the mind so
that everyone will you without there
you're putting out great content of what
people can do I don't think I don't I
don't think we do if I'm not worried
about it you surely shouldn't meaning we
just do your true stories are what
matters like you guys can you know like
it you know once you get to that place
where you're good with yourself and
you're trying to give back you only can
give back in your truth you know go
ahead but yeah
when I talk fifth grade 30 years ago or
25 years ago
taught kids I thought school Ballu as a
teacher yeah I thought I live I was in a
small city great I thought fifth grade
in fourth grade and he thought it was
bad for them or bad for you or bad
overall
yeah just garbage shows it's real bad
you know what's really sad is that's 25
years ago with the actualization of the
Internet it is so broken now because we
back to practicality it was already
somewhat bad it now makes absolutely
positively no sense we're making kids
eighty-five percent of the kids in this
country are memorizing information but I
think useful I don't know what to tell
you and and that is I selfishly as a 25
or 27 year old kid that kids sorry young
person mentally kid did some things in
my teaching to entertain me yes to make
my job more interest yes it made me a
far better teacher yeah they liked you
too
cuz you were a kid well I would be a
great teacher 42 right now I mean I want
to teach fifth grade right now so bad
you don't want to know I'm coming
guns-a-blazing but here's the thing the
best it was a great job one of the best
experiences I ever had that changed
everything and I wish every young person
could have this experience and it was by
mistake
Chason the cars and the watches and the
things all changed when they had this
unit and it was a bunch of file folders
worth a [ __ ] about the Holocaust and
about this yeah this was just terrible
so I said screw this I'm not doing any
of this and we did to our own mutant I'm
making kids you know we made blind here
and kids sit in the back for a couple
days we treated him like [ __ ] hmm
all sorts of make do any parents go and
this is a show you could do 25 years ago
you can't do that [ __ ] man know what we
did we tell you something we were we we
ended up bringing this is the one thing
I was done they probably won't but they
it was we brought a survivor from
Auschwitz oh and she said and the first
thing she did is she has shown a paper
bag with bologna sandwiches and she goes
I carry this everywhere because I the
closest I came to death was at 16 years
old when I took a bologna sandwich that
was moldy out of the garbage at the
guards hub that was beaten half to death
for him so everywhere I go I have a
bologna sandwich interesting little
privileged kids who look kind of [ __ ]
up
look at her and go why then she rolls up
the sleeve and showed her tattoo with
the normal and all of a sudden life got
real and I realized what she had done
was changed 30 lives that day
yeah and so I think the problem is and
you know this she changed 30 lives that
day for 24 hours the thing that I live
in is practicality yeah you're driving
fast one-handed [ __ ] being ridiculous
lights go on you [ __ ] your pants you
slow down it drives past you you're like
[ __ ] thank God right and then you are
kind of chilled for like about 12 15
minutes and then definitely by tomorrow
and most likely by the end of that trip
you're back right you go to the doctor
your blood test is weird they call you
back in you [ __ ] eat healthy that day
you [ __ ] are scared shitless you like
tell people you love them you're like
doing everything right false alarm
three days later you're back the thing
that I think I'm taking a lot of pride
in and this is the Internet this isn't
that I'm more special than other people
that had ambition
to communicate before me it's that the
reason I think I was able to I'm
creating more results is because I'm
consistent okay
and you made it very clear that the goal
shouldn't be I want to make a like a
million dollars when I'm 25 you know
it's just like I realize but I make but
I made it you know and listen some
people maybe you heard it from the first
podcast in the first video or maybe like
99.999% it was the first piece of
content that made you go down the rabbit
hole that then got you stuck and then I
pounded you for 187 days in a row and
then it was like wait a minute that
might be right because that's what this
that's that guy right you know cuz it
can't it can't there's no there's no one
piece of content it even like the song
you heard from the Rolling Stones or
Martin Luther King's it's yes in
hindsight but it's just the seed because
far more extreme versions don't change
us back to health scares so that's the
beauty of what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to gather all this attention to
keep it for a long enough period of time
then it actually makes an impact that's
why it's I think I'm resonating cuz it's
a change up your stories and your
content your subject so often to keep
everybody you know what's funny I think
that is actually less strategic and more
just who I am which is probably why I'm
like like that goes down to like other
things which is like you know that's
probably why that's probably why I was
bad like I don't keep myself interested
and I'm also you know what's funny that
I've sort of realized about myself is
I'm a big time listener even though like
on my shows I interrupt people and like
people like oh you know like you were
making a joke about yourself you know
you're gonna want to talk it's how you
do things but I'd be surprised if there
wasn't some listening from it I talked
so much to create listening
opportunities I'm throwing things at you
and watching how you're reacting or what
are you gonna bring up which gives me
white space to go into which manifests
in a new piece of content even the one I
just posted today like you know I've
kind of gotten to in the last couple of
weeks this idea
spin an idea before I've said it before
but I'm hot on it of like you're gonna
find what you're looking for you want to
find negativity you're gonna [ __ ]
find it let's go let's [ __ ] put on
[ __ ] CNN and Fox News let's go on
Twitter and like we can all [ __ ] think
the world's gonna end tomorrow or you
could go
you could go search on Twitter right now
thank you so much for and just see
unlimited stories of like you know you
know like unlimited stories of kindness
like go search what was what's so kind
to me go search on Twitter right now was
so kind to me I don't know you're just
gonna see all sorts of things like it
was really nice that this person was so
kind typically like helped me today or
like like so I'm fascinated right now of
like you'll find what you're looking for
you're looking for optimism you'll find
it you're looking for you know and
that's why back to mindset or the seed
or like what I'm trying to get through
like yeah I mean I think the thing that
I'm trying to do is take on the
responsibility that I have a mess that
I'm a personality and a human that
willowy has always had the ability to
resonate with youth and with elderly
like I would say I do better with 70 to
90 and 15 to 25 and I you know obviously
which is interesting cuz a lot of most
of this room isn't that but that is
where I win because if you're super
wisdom out you can see through
everything and you've got me pegged
quick nine-year-olds understand me
always the quickest and then 15
year-olds just get excited by my
communication style and I don't really
have a horse in a race I don't care why
somebody thinks I'm cool or worth
listening to I could care less I just
want them to listen because I know what
my intent is and I know that I can win
that game and I know I can keep their
attention and that's more out of it's
less strategy that I'm going to change
it this Thursday
babban will tell you probably cancer
it's literally like we're living I'll
say something
I get excited in my own [ __ ] on my own
number one fan it's just true I'll say
some of that oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] rad
and then oh like I'll put it in my head
and then again Bab in the virus and you
rock see it because they'll see it like
they now understand how I do it I've
learned through their eyes how I do it
which is I'll say something
I like how it feels what's that book to
wish you free in your bag yes yeah that
exactly stuff like that or like
something in here I like the way it
feels and then he'll see I'll use it
again tonight for a different and then
you know all of a sudden I'm doing it
and then like three weeks later it's the
thing all right it's cool it's been fun
to like learn it through the process
just that voice for a minute yeah get
some real state folks in the room and
just how would you do it you know I
think it's early for voice but I think
the number would like back the
practicality the first thing is
everybody should have an Alexa in their
home and you should force yourself to do
things with it
that don't come natural comes natural
saying play Billy Joel it comes natural
say what's the weather I'm trying to
break Alexa like a lot of like I'm
trying to I keep asking it's very easy
right now it's not that advanced but
it's helping me understate it's funny to
see what I'm trying to ask at things
what's coming out of my mouth like when
I when trying to make for tenant works
great just like I did with the iPhone
which eventually led to a lot of success
for me so I look at Alexa and Google
home like the iPhone it's a new platform
that's gonna get built on top of Twitter
Instagram Spotify ways these are all
apps on the iPhone
uber uber is an app on the iPhone and
Android so I don't think what Alexa does
today means anything to me I don't have
the right answer but like I couldn't
wrap my head around people not doing
things like so you understand voice is
gonna work in your car and your home and
it's gonna be in or compatible so like
this is real life to me what are we
night 2018 in 2027 a couple sitting on a
nice day like this on a Saturday morning
saying what do you want to do what do
you want to do like what are we gonna do
today we want to do anything today and
like one of them is gonna be like you
want to go to some open houses like I
don't know we want to move don't we
maybe we should go look at some houses
so like what happens in real life today
now they go to their computer and they
go on Google and they start looking
right we're gonna go on their foot like
that's real life to me you know Alexa
you know we like to go to some open
houses
Alexa's like I got you and you go in
your car and Alexa's like you're ready
and you're like yeah there you go there
that's real life that's exactly how it's
gonna work cuz it's faster it's like am
I gonna print something out from like I
did seven years ago put it on my phone
which means I can't then use my phone
Yeah right like so it's gonna do
everything that the phone does once you
understand that truth then you realize
what's different on voice then it is
unwritten and audio and video that's all
but it's gonna do everything like
scandal or that scandal serial right
that was the podcast that exploded like
that entertained us like people listened
to serial and podcast forum the way our
great-grandparents listened to the radio
in their living room and listened to
sitcoms that later became what old is
new what new is old everybody here is
going to be entertained everybody here
probably do all of you listen to a
podcast you had that wasn't real four
years ago
utility I mean I think so for example
Alexa Google home in the car in the real
estate business huge from utility which
brokerage or which macro brokerage is
gonna build the best app how are my
leads your leads earnest what are my
openings do any of my clients have an
opening in their calendar because their
calendars matched to Google think about
Google's infrastructure Google has
Google Calendar they have Google home
you do all you have to do is all off or
give permission to your Google home
device to have access to your calendar
all that I have to do as a contact of
yours is do that as well
now Google sits in the middle and I say
I really want to see babban Tuesday
April 13th would be best you both have
four hours of opening would you like me
to contact both of you yes I don't need
an assistant technology
I have a question sure okay so I am
reaching that plateau where it's just
like I only have so much time that's the
sort of thing to hire somebody yeah and
I want to do something else okay and
hiring a designer is hard because it's
like it's in your mind like designers
whatever but I'm very well aware that
websites like I'm not gonna be doing
websites and I'm like 34 years old right
and so I wanted someone in the tech
industry for a long time and with your
experience what should I be investing my
time in now to kind of be ahead of it so
the good news is design never goes away
as a macro it's design you know it's
like visual we will always look so it
will always know please do interrupt how
I started it as I started Facebook group
and that's how I got all my leads I
never paid for advertising what do you
think so I would just do like little
videos like tips marketing tips or
whatever and then that Facebook group
grew to like 5,000 but they're like
5,000 like very active members I totally
love them and so that's how I've been
getting my business so far so I don't
know if that helps any context you guys
can give me as always gonna help look I
think I think there you're asking two
different questions one is the output
and one is the lead gen 2 the output
right which both matter so the question
becomes which one are you most focused
on they both matter so I get that I get
it so the question is you know a couple
things one I would scratch your own itch
the first thing I would start with is
like what do you want to design you're
like like if you just you know you
didn't have money what would you want to
design you know and if that is as far
deviating as clothes instead of websites
that's something we need to talk about
you know if it's always on top of
technology interfaces well that's great
there's a lot to talk about
there's also different levels of design
you know some is just pure design maybe
sub is you I mean I don't know how much
you care about or do the UI in the UX
right so if it's more on the art side we
need to play that out but if it was on
the UI UX side which it's not which is
fine but if it was I'll tell you the
most interesting thing in the world
right now to me is the UI and UX of
voice we don't know how to talk to these
devices yet like why is there hashtags
on Twitter because Chris Messina
posted a tweet one day and said let's
start using hashtags and Twitter was so
small that the like 4,000 of us that
kind of ran [ __ ] we're like okay that's
literally why it happened like why do
you swipe up like why do you like like
why do we do everything we do people
made decisions they made design
decisions where do you find the vast
dy/dx people today what is your what is
it user interface and user design you
know it's just you know experience whose
are inoffensive experience I think is
what it stands for but like I just know
it as the you know the way it's referred
to it's it's the people that really sit
there and try to make things create the
least amount of friction to create the
results right right how do you take
friction at a system you should seem
winelibrary.com 1996 it's gonna be a
mathematician to place an order because
we don't know how to execute a shopping
cart and a you know like a like
everything right so the mouse is here or
how do you go you're on the top left
what colors are like all the stuff that
goes into a proper design for
functionality there's it's pretty
aesthetically it looks right it makes
you feel warm and then there's do
convert right there's a landing page
does it convert right how did he enter
the contest that he went into like you
know like got it okay
yep so super important you know like for
me it came natural to me because it's
how I thought about my dad's liquor
store because I was 14 and would stand
behind the register and I would just it
was not that busy so every customer you
could have to focus on like I would just
watch how they this is what I've done my
whole life I watch people so like I
would just watch how they would walk and
I'm like they're all going to the beer
section that's least less profitable
what if we like blocked it and made them
go this way I did that it worked
everybody picked up more
stuff it was crazy now you feel like
you're in control it's a fun job if
you're UI UX designer
it feels very powerful if you think
about it you're you're you're playing
maze with humans yeah the reason I asked
that you I've been through about 12 so
far on the next one and you know what's
tough right it's even more tough with
design like the biggest thing if you
want this scale let's say you just
wanted to do exactly what you're doing
and the answer scale it's a bet it's not
being the judge in the jury for the
client like your designers having to get
through you before they get to the
customer is your biggest vulnerability
because I am like can I give you a real
insight it's ego yeah I think I'm really
good at what I get it and guess what you
maybe I don't think anybody here gives
better marketing advice when they're
with a client but that's not what my
clients are paying for they're paying
for better marketing advice than the
alternative that what Berkshire was
doing with [ __ ] maquette McGary bone
or V video or whatever the good news is
it's way better with us now if I did it
personally it meaner but that's not what
we're selling here and that's what you
need to wrap your head around here's the
best part
some people hate your [ __ ] too like it's
not about 80 perc you've got it it's
about understanding that it's a
subjective call I'm just on emotional
ones people a lot of stress it will
relieve a lot way to taste it now we
went through your head you like that
makes oh wait that's a different way to
look at it but what you need to do is
make sure that you don't undermine your
employee so a lot of people listen to me
on this and they're like that makes
sense and are pumped then they hired
then they stopped doing it differently
but what they're doing is they're subtly
undermining their own employee because
they like the feeling the client thinks
they're better it's ego it's ego ego is
killing people you know it's funny I'm
such a frontman for my company and I
have my personality but again like a
promise you babban the biggest insight
will be like the humility more than the
or the lack of like touching everything
the economy so like not only do you have
to let it go and let somebody do their
thing and you shouldn't even I mean the
only reason you should approve is if
something's completely off the
reservation only if it's completely off
the reservation so I think I watched
baboons first four seven nine help me
here because it was I was watching all
the daily bees back then took me a
little while to like let go with daily
because there's so much sensitive
information so but I have now which is
crazytown because we're filming some
[ __ ] snuck into the franchise owner
breakfast San Antonio a month ago and
your team was there and they did I mean
they're just
you got some personalities there that
was awesome but I noticed you didn't you
they didn't feel you were mentioned and
then we get in just in the background
building up there but it was nothing to
do with Gary B yes it was about it yeah
I mean the philosophy the philosophy of
this company is built by me but yeah I
mean look it's even funnier than that
even look at this like all I'm really
like even if it's me in the room all I'm
trying to do is figure out you look if
you're if you have customers it's about
the customer well you know it's a boy
you know sometimes it may seem heavier
than others only if my team feels that
they need to use me as in the same way
that I'm trying to be a shield for you
guys like my great goal right now is to
help people that are insecure use me as
what 2.2 to be in the argument at home
well Gary Vee Slyke to me I want people
to say Gary Vee said not cuz it feeds my
ego because it gives them courage to
finally have the conversation
information
so my team can use me if they feel like
they need to tool in the toolbox and let
you grow that you can't go we 100% 100%
I just yeah I just would have never been
anything that matched my ambition like
if my ambition was far smaller yet
ridiculously huge this would be what I
would be doing for a living I would just
hang out with businesses and make a
fortune make a million dollars a day I
make a million dollars a day enjoying
the [ __ ] I'd make a million dollars a
day being put on a pedestal yes and
getting my ego stroked all day yet I run
a business that made 1.4 million in
profit last year because I invested all
back in the business that's me eating my
own dog food that's me at 42 speaking
about patience and building to the long
term because you just don't go from zero
to buying the Jets on a singular move
it's not how it works I'm trying to go
direct to the consumer yes I ask the
flower HJC contractor you know it really
starts off with whom really is our
customers yeah some of the one things my
how much does it cost a whole house
system installed a plumber would charge
about $5,000 well first they're rich
let's start with how much twenty five
hundred bucks let's start with their
rich okay yeah but that helps well sure
when you when you think about who your
customer is yeah sometimes when you're
in your own business it's hard to
understand certain things like this like
that's a fuckload of money yeah
tabs like that's a really good starting
point yeah well one of the things that
we were thinking about is like who's our
end customer that so who's rich for this
thing and we say well what yeah and one
of the things we talk about is obviously
people who have you know kids and I've
got a twenty two week old baby so I'm
like so you know because you have enough
money I'm trying to help you here okay I
don't give a [ __ ] how many kids you have
right twenty-five hundred bucks is a ton
of money to the average person for a
water system okay because when you don't
have if you're not making over $100,000
you're probably more like the water at
your sink is more than fine yeah
delicious so would that change then so
how it would change everything okay so
that's why I'm zoning notice okay so how
then would I you know if I'm gonna look
at obviously people who have it's who
are rich okay so where would I
where would I what would be the starting
point for you would be content about
what I'd be doing kind of about what's
going on with me and my daughter like no
there's a lot of places to go so let's
let me before I jump to conclusions
though I did and I feel like I'm right
about that one conclusion help me break
it down what is it you come into
people's homes and what it's a water
filtration so the water coming out of
your sink is yeah it's like what I have
because I'm rational everything in your
house has going to be filtered right
your watch so everyth right
cook with me that's right now that's
right well first let's have the most
interesting part of the conversation
sure why is that a good idea well from
your selfish point of view I mean in
terms of people don't realize how bad
the chlorine is and the water and if
you're bathing your kids or bathing
yourself so well dad don't care she okay
you probably go to the hair salon and
spend a lot of money on your hair don't
you ok we'll pretend that a lot of our
you know spouses significant others they
go to the hair salon they some of us
enough money they come home and the
first thing they do is they wash their
hair right well they smell them it says
money to get their hair colored that
chlorines like stripping the hair color
flat out of her hair because chlorines
actually technically it's a it's a
poison I mean people don't realize it's
it's a poison and then what it does to
your skin so if you've got a baby and we
talk about baby you know soft skin
so the thing the thing I would say is my
big thing is the most important part
when you mark it is to focus on the
black and white truths and work
backwards okay so I feel like the most
interesting part of this discussion with
you right away is where does the data
break down let me explain the wine
business I sold wine four years back in
1990 two three four when I was a kid
but it was the heyday because 60 minutes
did a piece on the French paradox and
the tired thesis was people in France
are living longer even though they have
fatty foods because there's products in
wine that are so healthy for you that
you will live longer Rivest for all I
think I'm forgetting already it's been
so long since once I understood the next
part which was that was it it was
accepted 60 minutes
doctors accepted that this chemical the
best Raleigh [ __ ] I can't remember I
can't believe I forgot it's better for
you is good for you is great for the
heart and a lot of you have grandparents
or older uncles or parents that started
drinking wine in the mid 90s because it
was good for your heart this was real
life in America glass of a right then
six years seven years later which is why
I can't even remember the chemical right
now or the additive or whatever the [ __ ]
it is which I can't believe it makes me
feel like I'm getting a locust I
remember everything and this was like
the core of my life then it came out
that yes that's true but you need to
drink 64 gallons of wine to get the
benefit that they were in UN doing right
and I'm exaggerating but I think it was
legitimately like 10 cases it was
something no human could ever even do
once let alone in any kind of
common-sense way to me if I bought 50
percent of your business 49 and we
started here day 1 and we're about to go
into marketing plan I'd probably spend 3
to 4 meaningful weeks really feeling if
there was something we could mark it on
because my cynicism is you're right but
not at the dosage that we're being
deployed in our water I could be wrong
I'm telling you as a common sense human
when I hear that as the marketing lead
I'm like [ __ ] you you're doing that for
your self-interest the reality is is if
that if it was so harmful we would have
been [ __ ] so long ago because every
day
everybody's pouring now you may counter
and properly with like yeah yeah but
like the subtleties matter like if you
have if you have
what's that skin thing psoriasis
psoriasis or eczema thank you like if
you [ __ ] have that like it's a little
but that really impacts you for you Gary
maybe you don't have that and yeah
you're right and maybe if you don't
color your hair so I think there's a
couple things number one I think the
biggest mistake marketers make is they
lead with something that the whole
industry leads with that actually
doesn't matter to the audience let me
explain another one just to get this in
your head when Dollar Shave Club came
out I saw it my father-in-law work that
Gillette is a top executive they'd
solved the company to Procter & Gamble
but the guy was still there the CEO Jim
kilt was still on the board I had a good
relationship I saw a moment where I
could be historically right with like a
legendary guy and I was like I'm gonna
go for it so I called him like hey I
just saw a startup it's called Dollar
Shave Club they just had a viral video I
think this is something he proceeds to
tell me and laughed me out of the room
on the phone by saying Gary we spend
more money in R&D than they will raise
in capital in their history and he goes
and look our sheave is a hundredth of a
16 inch better for the man than theirs
could ever be and I go and that's why
you're gonna lose cuz there's not a
single [ __ ] guy in America or the
world that gives a [ __ ] that their shave
is a hundredth of a 16th inch cleaner
than it was the last time and I was
right people cared it was a dollar a
hell of a lot more than they did about
the hundredths of a 16th inch so a
couple things number one your as a lead
is always capped we discovered that and
good really loved it so fear isn't great
so I'm glad you're past that there's a
lot and it's a super interesting
business first of all I think I think
just what I would argue that everything
we just talked about is actually
ironically secondary and that there's
just a lot of people that are willing to
buy it if you made the friction of them
buying it easier okay just back to your
first point which is you just marking it
or just you mark it look when you have
this the fact that you can target fans
of the Kardashians on Facebook and have
$100,000 income and live in your town
you've already got four customers from
Facebook tomorrow like these claims or
statements right where are we there's
public domain right yeah they gave them
they they were customers on but they
will they said yeah go ahead use use I
mean you're off to the races
yeah I need them actually friendly with
you like beyond I mean I don't talk to
any of you you know yeah remarkly out
all the headaches did they free do they
say yes through their plumber or you
guys reached out to them no you know an
interesting thing was that I found a I
found a company that was doing gift bags
for celebrities for like that happened
them the Grammys and that happen to
offer your system I said yeah let's put
my system in there and that's how I
that's how I got you mate you put these
in there for free in their home for free
I get smart yeah I believe in that [ __ ]
I'm Leben free a lot which the design
community hates me for no [ __ ] you and
everybody else and then when people make
it they tell everybody not to give it
for free because they don't like the
competition [ __ ] [ __ ]
pisses me off they act like they're
noble to all the kids hey designers
don't give away its your net worth and
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] I know for a fact
you work for free in the beginning and
now that you [ __ ] charge $1,000 an
hour you don't want the supply and
demand to change piece of [ __ ] and
pisses me off you know look I think do
you have a way to capture the business
now on your website direct or not yet
well we're we've got a transition so
we've got our existing site now that our
plumbers use and whatnot and we've had a
transition site that were that we want
to launch to go direct to the consumer
we've done some AdWords testing we're
getting the good news is and we're
getting people to the site the bad news
is they're not by seeing a mini opening
yeah I actually got two different videos
and it's why you can't talk about me
that one is a
benefit based ones more of a health
scare type based so we've got both
angles covered so understood yeah
there's a couple of different things
that are running through my mind what I
think about b2b in this sense a lot so
one of the things that I think is super
interesting is getting to the developer
level and having it default into the
homes okay and then I'm thinking about
what could you possibly bring benefit to
those homes so one of the things I think
a lot there's a big arbitrage right now
of people that know how to market one of
the reasons I want you to market
progressively is just to capture the eye
of the developers in your region or in
the country so that I could see
something like the Toll Brothers company
default putting this into their homes of
a certain income level in return for you
teaching them how you marketed b2b
transactions on social media I know that
super likely it's fine because we me
giving plumbers to to carry this out I
had a business model to do that but it
was getting them to actually do
something was the difficult part getting
there
so I'm him the business owner the
plumbing company I'm able to get him to
say yeah I want to sell your product but
then to get his actual plumbers to do it
is you know there's a whole other do it
yeah yeah see where I'm going yeah yeah
at one point you believe dollar houses
be included yeah all right let me keep
thinking okay so give it away so I have
a my project a planner for loan officers
real estate agents tape Leno 25 bucks
for they buy subscription annual
subscription and we're new balloon on 20
version is in the works right now what's
cool about 2,000 users that I've been
just giving away instead of selling
probably because if you give it away and
you make it up on the margin on the back
end premiums always a better model less
friction let me phrase that's not fair
freedom is not always a better it's
always fun to try the alternative if you
feel you've capped out so I'm not I'm
glad I just corrected myself
I love freemium I think it's very smart
you give something a piece of value
you've got them into a
revenue system they feel like the thing
they got for free pays for even the
thing like it's a good business idea but
it's not the only one like I mean you
know paying a premium up you know the
other argument would be to charge them
more like there's so many you know I'm
always fascinated everything between a
number and $99 interests me I'm
fascinated by anything I think there's
two thresholds 20 and hundred I'm very
fascinated about this consumer behavior
that I believe I believe that if you're
under 20 like 20 is the first hurdle but
I hate it 25 it's 35 individuals 90 yeah
yeah to me that's where it gets fun
I love that like that place there was
some woman's that came to 4ds and I told
her to like take her $63 product $2.99
and she's like made a fortune because
there's just no difference where I think
we're very basic 2,100 so we can tell
advertising so when we advertise then
try the different price points to see
what so you could you could and then
give it away I think one of the things -
one more time this is a planner which is
a utility for them to be more efficient
right tell them track their time track
their activities and their results so
they can determine what activities and
so I have to assume it's skews older
because of the format of what it is it's
not it's really interesting yeah we have
younger people who like also know
Michael thank you yeah and that's gonna
continue to grow out to get a piece out
I think actually more people will buy
this to help support that I think that
might be right right thing somewhere
during today I mean they're right it's
on and then what else and then they're
paying you what Japan well so they're
most people are buying subscriptions so
and so what is the description give them
for 99 bucks use it every quarter ships
out so the antiquary shows us and
there's no other products or services no
I'm right now we were free like 68 week
starboard out was content to help them
fear how to use it have you thought
about adding the level of once a quarter
like so you know she had a group his
business is built like this have you
thought about doing once a quarter a one
hour you know virtual seminar with
everybody who's bought it
we've got a small you know it's not
taken off yet Facebook group yep and
doing some what are you doing in there
for it to take that off right that's the
that's the challenge we're trying to
figure out what's gonna go and then
we're doing like I just bring into two
webinars one next week one week after
one I'll tell you what I'll tell you one
thing that always works and it's what
I'm doing with you like if you've got
expertise which is what scares a lot of
people from doing what I'm about to say
but when you have expertise Q&A is the
greatest it's the greatest I mean like
this is the best format ever you're
asking me what you want to know like I
mean what what could possibly be better
because when I want to talk to you
getting that for free if you want to
watch it or listen to it anyway I would
making it more of a community it's very
obvious to me why her business is doing
well she's actually manifest in a 5,000
she's created a 5,000 person community
they give a [ __ ] Facebook live with you
you could you could do Facebook live you
could use there's you know you could do
sky there's a million things you could
do in cigarette you could try a lot of
different things I'm less worried about
the technology that's so advanced now
the reason I'm hesitating and just
saying Facebook live is it may make
sense for you to use something else that
collects first party data you may want
to invest a couple like that so people
to call in have to give you more data
when you're not at the mercy of Facebook
so there's a million ways to think about
this but I what I think is clear is you
haven't layered the high-touch
stickiness to the business yet which I
think will create more word-of-mouth and
may evolve here's here's why I like
doing stuff like this it may lead to
something I want to do we don't get into
the trenches enough I promise you this
is what always makes me laugh about
things like this I would have made the
New York Times list anyway I didn't I
didn't you know the value exchange on
350 books at eight times eight is not
gonna be a good ROI for me in two hours
ever and I was laugh when people like
will say something about this or
anything else I do and they're like it's
so funny how not thoughtful people are
like to me the reason I do this is I
want to force myself through short-term
little fun needs to get into the
trenches this is the trenches
and people don't like the trenches
trenches are hard all the magic evidence
100% but it's but we're all trying to
figure out scalability and like what are
the like it's much more fun as a
solopreneur or small business including
mine to think about the scalable aspect
versus the digging deep especially when
you've been through it the youngsters
here on their journey like you and I
look at the minute you should be putting
in the [ __ ] work but we've been
putting in the work for 20-30 years it's
like [ __ ] we have to put in the work
yep sure do you gotta put in just as
much they need to put in the work as
they need to establish putting in the
work we need to put in the work because
we can get caught into our lazy habits
and the next guy or girl is right behind
us ready to put us out of business this
is capitalism so why I hate capitalism
in America in its current form which is
you work you're a so if you kill
somebody you're it's a dog-eat-dog world
and then you become rich and you want to
use your money to not allow it to change
so you can hold on to your money
we're in fake capitalism in America now
[Music]
old dudes are trying to change the rules
so that they can keep the money because
they don't want the young lionesses to
take their [ __ ] and the internet by the
way it's the internet that's gonna solve
it he's an a mystery than the average
ages and their kiddies right in there
Brian that's it right yeah real estate
is a great business like as long as we
live on this earth it will have value
but like where like to me the
recommendation I give all my friends
like by Manhattan its Manhattan and be
ok if it goes down third like never
invest something you can't afford to
lose completely because then you won't
have to invest pull out like you won't
get caught in the margins everything I
have in Wall Street which I don't trust
those [ __ ] down there with anything
is completely predicated on that I will
never look at it for the rest of my
entire life it doesn't exist that is why
it's good to build a personal brand
because it's yours in any market but it
has to be built on truth and merit and
what I'm worried about is everybody's
getting ahead like Gary conferences Gary
didn't I don't have any money I'm in
debt I'm like I'm like let me go climb
seventy thousand dollars of credit for
that yes what do I do like the first
thing you do is [ __ ] sell the eight
thousand dollar suit
wearing yeah yeah but I was told that I
have to look the part that like I mean
just [ __ ] yeah that's the other thing
that scares me too is because we've been
just as a company people know it's as a
company they don't know me personally
because we have such a big team now
that's well slowly instead of [ __ ]
razz pizzazz on [ __ ] Instagram right
a thoughtful six years into my journey
peace on LinkedIn right a [ __ ] post
right now on LinkedIn tonight called six
years in or to make it clever
so we're I'm creative like four hundred
sixty-five two thousand days into my
journey a manifesto you know or when
you're writing and you realize wait a
minute writing about nine things I've
learned so cool nine things I've learned
in my first two thousand days in
business post link in your email bio
underneath all your information CEO
co-founder right slowly but surely it's
tortoise versus the hare brother it's a
[ __ ] as simple as that is what's so
confusing is I have the energy of a
super hair but the actions of a tortoise
appreciative do that now I just say that
so much of the advice given is finish
line driven right they like there's
actually something out there whether
it's recognition whether it's and what
you said it early on and that if you
realize that the the win the finish line
is the journey it's over yeah it's over
yeah and then and then it being flexible
enough to allow yourself to adjust you
know life changes when you have a child
you know he's a different man at twenty
two then he has a twenty eight there's a
you know you can't beat yourself up for
changing your mind you just have to be
thoughtful and self-aware of why you're
changing your mind
sure maybe the person fall in love with
is materialistic and you're just in love
with him or her you just are [ __ ] love
them you want to marry them and they
love [ __ ] so all of a sudden you're
buying [ __ ] that you never bought before
that's not there's nothing necessarily
wrong with that as long as you're
grounded into what's happening right
like you're super proud of yourself and
never spending money on anything and you
kept the basic but then you fall in love
and he or she wants [ __ ] a fancy belt
with the
go on it you know like every and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that
because I have my own versions maybe I
don't want to wear fashion brands and
watches but I like buying custom jet
jerseys of random bench players you know
that's a waste of a hundred fifty bucks
for a custom Jersey of a guy who might
not be on the team in two months
but when I go to a Jets game and people
like you have a blank blank Jersey
that's me peacocking that I'm the best
fan so it's okay but what's not okay and
what I'm trying to fix is you're doing
it to hide your insecurities that you
haven't made it yet that's not okay
because you'll lose you will lose if you
want a BMW on money you don't have
because you want to look good
amongst your pure set that you've made
it and you haven't you will lose you
will lose especially during the Serie
right now where the market is good if
you're not winning right now you really
[ __ ] suck it's the truth because this
is not [ __ ] you know 2001 this is not
2008 you know any less people buy water
filtration systems when the [ __ ]
market collapses less people give me
less people buy [ __ ] cases of $4,000
wine like today this is happening at
Wine Library when the market collapses
less people you know many less people
are buying [ __ ] homes a lot less
people
real life and like what's so fun for me
is this is 100% I will not live the rest
of my life in a bullish market and
growth
so like recalling like I can't wait to
air this content the day the whole
[ __ ] world melts and it's gonna be
like I told you so
and I hope you did something about it
because now it gets really weird I'm
gonna be so right about that I'm gonna
be so historically right about that
they're lending money to kids in hugely
but there's nothing else to say there's
nothing else to say the banks are doing
it again this time it's not [ __ ]
Morgan things you guys understand better
I don't still don't fully I mean I
understand packaging up or [ __ ] and not
having a true recognition or a true
system they're like you you guys
probably in the younger set part you
guys know your friends or acquaintances
who are a hundred eighty thousand in
debt a nine percent interest are making
47 thousand a year and are buying
expensive [ __ ] or have a new apartment
it's going to be so bad here two or
three things you might tell literally a
minute you might tell new or a newer
real okay so I think the real estate
industry I know a lot about it my sister
just became one too and like we threw a
conference like I know it really well
and have spoken at I know it thank you
first of all I think it trades too much
on its history I think the old guard
much like marketing is respected too
much and I think that's a fundamental
starting point like it's so funny I'm
talking like it's so funny how can't I
love how I think about the world cuz
it's in opposite directed out old school
tactics and my opening line is like
don't [ __ ] respect the old school but
I do think that a lot of the advice kit
you said new right there getting advice
from old school dogs who are saying [ __ ]
that isn't relevant anymore they're just
i blown away by the enormity of advice
that's like I mean I don't know like I'm
just like just like a lot of tried and
true that isn't tried and true the only
reason we're getting away with it is
that they built up enough of a base and
a reputation they're trading off their
brand
and the reputation not off of the new
tactics but if you're new and you're 24
and nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are
you're not trading on your reputation
that's number one
look I think it's completely I think
social media
aka Facebook and Instagram especially
but I do think LinkedIn even in a
real-estate world is really tricky
interesting Google YouTube pre-rolls for
sure like if you are not a practitioner
of modern-day marketing you are
irrelevant so I think you're in the
business of being good at Facebook and
Instagram and Linkedin and YouTube comma
real estate agent and when you make that
decision I think that's true for all of
you like if you actually think you're a
marketing company for your company first
whether you then go hire somebody to do
it because you've become educated and
somebody can't rip you off or you
actually fall in love with it and do it
in parallel or what I'm starting to see
from people is I taught them to do it
they got good at it and you know what
happens you you know you're here you're
living it already then people want to
pay you to do it for them all of a
sudden you're you build a fifteen
million dollar agency for plumbers to
market their business I mean it's real
life and that's where people struggle
with do I stay the course of my business
do I become the personality and make
money that way or do I start a service
business or that well I'm sure this is
run through everybody's listening around
there's you know so I mean I choke the
you know it's funny I chose to do in a
very weird way I chose to do it
I build wine library based on the
machine that is vaynermedia but I'm not
trying to build vaynermedia I'm trying
to build vaynermedia to then go back and
build businesses on the back of it right
you see where I'm going I did it then I
built a service business for it with the
idea then to make it so at scale that I
could do it bigger badder than ever that
I could buy Schweppes for 200 million
and then make everybody in America drink
ginger ale because I'm gonna get lil
yachty and Instagram models drinking
Schweppes
and Schweppes will have the best voice
app and there'll be pre-roll schweppe
ads for direct-to-consumer because you
once searched ginger ale on google and
now you're watching a fishing video and
it'll come out of the water system
that's right the business model if you
don't mind could you elaborate on that
sure build yours and of what you're
doing for companies now meaning one more
time one make sure I understand the
question
Maynard we're talking about Vayner is a
client service business we get paid we
said we sell people right it's a really
bad business it's a bad business even
when I think you've run it well we don't
run it well because it's not its intent
but even a tenner I mean look it's a
good business it will probably
eventually be doing five hundred million
at fifteen percent net profit that's a
good business I don't want to pee on it
right but it's it's a difficult business
you're at the mercy of people just
people I'm in the HR business 24/7 you
know which is fine I like that you know
to me I come up with the products and
service the some of the services are
obvious right paid media like wheel
spend your media you'll pay us a
commission on that like that's under but
where do you put your focus we did on
Facebook seven years ago so now we're a
leader back to if I sold things if I was
willing to do Google and if I was
willing to do Direct Mail like I would
have been bigger because that's where
people are paying for at the time so my
model is bet on something you believe in
build towards that goal out far enough
that you become the leader but not too
far that you go out of business before
you get there and then my plan is to
take the best talent here and deploy it
against other things that I buy or start
so I'm thinking about starting a men's
shampoo brand because I actually don't
think there's any shampoo brand that
speaks to us for real like what dub
men's so I like I will take four pieces
of talent from here they'll no longer
work on client business and they'll be
the this that and the art the creative
the media the strategy and so I'm
building an infrastructure
but you have to reverse engineer
yourself you guys know me a little bit
better you got a better sense for me
even right now this would break if I
wasn't a good guy because this is
completely being held up by HR this this
is being held up on the fact that
Babbitt doesn't want to leave so when
babban goes and starts working for the
men's media company that I'm launching
this summer which is probably true other
than I love him so much I'll have to
keep him once in a while for like
blogging for me like the thing that's
making him not leave is me otherwise he
would and that was his game plan what
was it again Bobby bad and how many and
how long are we in now and what's right
you know I know you that you'll tell the
truth what are you thinking now you know
and whether that's three you know and
whether that's three years or nine or 17
or life you know he'll evolve his like
back to you know I'm always in the
mindset of he'll phone what if he falls
in love with somebody that comes to one
of these events who she lives in India
and that's it he has to move to me like
that's cool
that's life I'm always open for
everything like that's I know what my
plans are I've built the framework my
preferences it works on everybody
forever it's okay if it doesn't but that
was me betting up like this is a very
unique company that's very difficult to
replicate because I'm unique but you're
all unique in your way and you need to
figure that out I'm very big on
deploying against your strengths like
make content that fits you like if
you're in a serious business I was in a
premium wine business and was ridiculous
with my content I'm some $150 bottles of
wine referencing Hillbilly Jim taking a
crap since I'm like jumping for working
on how do I know that this is
I want to do for the rest of my life you
know I think you've heard this probably
about love too and I mean this I think
you'll just know
I really do what's gonna happen is
you're gonna have the when you really
know in business it's gonna be two
things very early significant success
and you're loving it for not the money
that's why all the other stuff matters
so much if you're not trying to catch up
to Rick if you're not trying to impress
Sally then the then the way you're gonna
know is you love it for loving it not
for the money it's giving it to you so
many of my internet contemporaries
because I can't call them friends
because I can't be friends with somebody
like this love stuff because of the
money they loved affiliate marketing
because of the money they love network
marketing and MLM because of them money
if you're the kind of person that's okay
with like ripping people off for your
own self gain because you need the money
and you're that insecure yeah I'm not
gonna Joe the [ __ ] am i I'm not gonna
judge you it's just not my cup of tea
it's not who I am or what I'm about or
who I want to associate with I don't
care how fast your car is or how hot
your chicks are just not interested it's
gonna be fun of us
because if I don't figure out what I
wanted to kill I graduate my name is
probably gonna pull my ears and put him
in his business
that makes sense second it the good news
is you don't have to go you think you
have to go because you're letting them
have a leverage point and that leverage
is normally money not love kids love to
say kids everybody comes up with excuses
kids too
you love to say you don't want to let
your dad down what you mean is you're
not sure how you're gonna maintain a
decent lifestyle it's people's inability
or want to pay the price for the big
stuff which is what crazy to me in
college because that's when you should
find your homies Pacolet the number one
piece of advice I have if you're a
winner is find three other winners look
at each other and say 22 to 27 we're
together let's [ __ ] go and now with
the internet when people building
businesses you don't need a New York or
San Francisco or San Diego go into
Mississippi cost of living is low go
live right next to a [ __ ] White
Castle that you can walk to being
serious by the way as long as you have
internet connection
let's go like I'm giving you my dream I
wish I knew that I wanted to pay back my
parents for what they did for me it
wasn't a drag I signed up for going
there for a while building something for
them I like not owing anybody anything
and I love the feeling that my parents
and I are even which is a rare thing for
a kid to say especially with the
amazingness that my parents are and what
they did for me and we're probably still
not even because they [ __ ] really did
it for me
but I like it I'm a hell of a lot closer
than most people because I really did
something for them for real and so
that's cool so I like that but if I
didn't have that gear or that well
parented if it was a like if I [ __ ] me
man
nothing's more interesting right now
than to go to Mississippi with my five
college friends and literally there's
nothing like building something
like it was much more fun before it was
six figures those first few right
there's nothing like building something
right of course this is all the burden
now it's so fun when you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're doing it up and you're
just trying to figure it out and you're
just [ __ ] ghetto to the max that's
what I want that's what I'd listen I
like Rocky when he's drinking the AEGON
[ __ ] it like I like that that's why I
want people to love the process and it
gets a lot harder to love the process
when you have a husband and wife kids
stuff the big mistake is not the making
of the money it's the spending of the
money I want to think about it that's
that's the thing that when we push it
back on college the thing is that so
many of them I think know that the big
companies want you to have a degree
correct right but I don't think I don't
think that that matters right it doesn't
matter here anymore and we're hiring a
ton of people that'll instead of them
going and spending thirty fifty thousand
dollars - it makes no sense right it's
so broken it's trading on it's trading
on two things historical truth which yes
if you wanted to get a job in 1989 in
America that was good it was a really
good idea and insecurities of parents
yeah to trade on the brand that their
kids go to so they can look good to
their other friends I think the
companies can be the actually new
universities they will be human the
whole thing the whole it's over you have
there's my it's over the Internet's the
middle yeah I mean it doesn't make send
if you're not native to it you're if
you're not and that doesn't mean like
the it doesn't mean that brokers real
estate agents get replaced what it means
is brokerages get replaced like people
don't get it like it's like the end
person it's hard to replace like a
robots not gonna show her the house so
fast but everything else like Vayner
brokerage like I've thought about it a
ton through the last three years I'm
like man like one of the reasons
Berkshire is a lot of fun for me is I
get to learn it as well and like the big
thesis of Vayner is to learn it now I've
so
things I'm gonna do so I'm not gonna go
into the businesses of any of my clients
like the first thing I'll do is
something completely different than
anybody we ever had and we're getting
big and substernal eliminate things so
I've actually said no to some things
recently because I'm like well [ __ ] I
may want to do a bottled water you know
anyway nonetheless but [ __ ] man I
already know it didn't take that many
meetings and I knew it before I even
grabbed them and I kind of said yes
because of Gino - it's really funny we
both did the same [ __ ] thing yeah is
is um I mean Vayner you know there's -
like my brokerage would destroy
everybody's house in Berkeley because
everything is a commodity other than
building up the agent and I know how to
build up the agent a hell of a lot
better than giving you a book of leads
and J ving and giving you a [ __ ]
business card and the you were like are
you [ __ ] kidding me
that sort of leverages so super
interesting that's the whole leverage of
everything comms is the leverage
communication marketing like that's the
leverage for anything like as long as
your products not a piece of [ __ ] the
variables are happening in the marketing
and the positioning in the brand and and
you've got kids that are going into math
but math is not how you sell Nike so you
could be awesome at Google on Facebook
but you have to build brand - and then
you have the big companies that don't
care about the new math and so that's
what a delta is you got to respect the
art and the science of the new world the
other thing is what's gonna replace at
that college level their ability to
interact face-to-face okay like a life
yeah they got a life yeah the hyperbole
and [ __ ] of like I'm gonna send my
kid to a campus and that's where he or
she is gonna become a man or woman and
like get life skills is horseshit it's a
fake environment life life is gonna make
them a man like life it's crazy like
when people like all that I'm like okay
then like I don't think it paid for half
the year to do something and then let's
send them on you'll get a hell of a lot
more life and fun like let's put them
all on a [ __ ] cruise for two weeks
like I mean it's it's it's so broken
yeah it's so broken it's gonna come down
look look but we're really bad at is
respecting history in 1951 nobody gave a
[ __ ] about college than they did
but it wasn't the American dream or the
bust you got Vic you got skills you were
taught skills in high school you know
and you were taught skills and you went
and got a job and then through a lot of
smart positioning and marketing and
behavior of the big business like
college was able to win at the default
for us you had to at least go to a
community college guess what you still
got debt there too if you don't have the
money to pay all this is 16 yeah you're
in a funny spot right now right because
probably what you thought ten years ago
has been affected by you just see if
you're sitting here you're affected by
the truth meaning I don't know where you
sit on college or not but I promise you
it hasn't gained momentum from ten years
ago
it can only be neutral like if you loved
it if you were an academic and like you
loved right for your parents like if
you're an academic if you were a college
professor and over the last ten years
there's no way you believed in it more
you're holed you may believe in the same
because you haven't allowed to hear
what's happening but if you're an
average parent right now with a 16 year
old
you'd probably believe in college less
than you did 10 years ago but you're
still of the parenting generation that's
caught you'll I've got a I went to
school for six years never graduated
write it all I but I learned there how
to manipulate now I mean the kind of
stud and you learn systems right my wife
on the other hand she graduated in early
childhood education associates a product
I had completely opposites at this point
yeah they need to go to college and I'm
like they don't need college at all
right so it's but you're gonna are you
gonna pay for college if she's doing
this boy or girl is you gonna pay for it
I don't know how many no I don't correct
you you just know that you you're a good
enough guy or your hope like what you
actually just answered is I'm not gonna
force him and not pay that's right
that's my biggest problem the biggest
problem this system right now is parents
are forcing their kids to go and on pay
parents are that the biggest problem of
college is parents for being pieces of
[ __ ] they're forcing their kids to
collect debt to make themself look good
was on September 9th or August 16 when
the kid goes away and they go out to
dinner with their friends whose kid also
went our way and Ricky went to Princeton
I feel great Ricky's about the [ __ ]
being $400,000 in debt and Ricky luckily
is going to Princeton so probably he he
can get a job at Bain & McKinsey or
Goldman Sachs and so probably after
seven years he'll get there but that's
the 1% the kid that's go to Penn State
that's getting [ __ ] eighty nine
thousand one hundred eighty nine
thousand dollars in debt who parents
feel good because they only went to
Community College but Penn State seems
like a level up but they're not paying
they're not the money and they're making
you go that's the norm and that kid
isn't graduating Penn State in 2022 with
anything even with parents and it was so
I'm not mad at people like it was a good
idea in 78 right was a good idea I think
that was jobs lined up for you that was
became the new norm and the same way
skills are now gonna become the new norm
like I mean I don't know we're babban
what the [ __ ] college I looked at the
video yeah I don't know if you went to
college
Sherman like like like which probably
like you know like all those one views
to potential so like every day when I've
decided okay close call 10 businesses
one day but I don't and then pushing
myself as some of the other excuses yeah
because I know in the back of a mile
that's got a business I'm good
so how do I stop Washington less of an
excuse look the fact that you could even
articulate that question has you so much
further along than anybody anybody who
has the ability to say dad as a business
I'm good you've been listening so you're
already on your honestly I don't even
want to answer your question because I'm
already happy for you you're on the way
one thing I would say there was full
potential or ten calls these are
arbitrary things
what's full potential I can't define
that these are things we're imposing in
ourselves why is ten calls the magic
number to feel good about yourself
right why couldn't it be 3 or 700 got it
so know what's real and what's not real
you said a very important real thing
which is you're concerned that the
cushion is siphoning out your ambition
that's up to you here's what I can tell
you you want it my one man lives life
where regret is the only thing that's
scary so you know you know it's probably
you know everyone's wired differently
like to me the thought of somebody
saying that I think one of the reasons I
own nothing of being our tongue I've
been talking a lot more about not owning
anything of Wine Library because I
didn't want people as I've gotten more
popular and in putting pressure on the
system people are pushing back at me who
are trying to get your money and are
saying well he was handed everything and
I was like [ __ ] I always protected my
dad because I was thought it was a
little weird that I never owned anything
but now I'm getting into even more of an
honest place to be very frank my most
honest place baboon's never heard this
first time ever saying it out loud I
think I secretly made sure I didn't own
any of it you know he wasn't asking he
wasn't giving and I wasn't asking it
took two to tango I didn't put pressure
my dad to give me anything in the
business because I think for me
subconsciously and maybe consciously
after I got to about 28 or 29 but
definitely not a twenty three or four
but definitely a 28 29 30 I realized I'd
was on my way to doing things and I
didn't need anybody to have an excuse
and I didn't want anybody to say I was
successful because of that so you just
need to try to get to know yourself are
you okay with people no Matt are you
okay with taking over so you may say I'm
gonna go into the business and I'm gonna
make it 500 times bigger you may say
that's yourself and then you may say
well that will prove that I'm good or
what have you and then I would say to
you but people are gonna still come up
with excuses that you know and so you
just kind of know yourself you know you
just got to know yourself
interesting so you're not letting good
get in the way of grades you just don't
want to be distracted by comfortable
right it's like safe and comfortable
what kind of business is it it's kind of
like Time Warner we we supply internet
and cable to seven states in India
and is that your dad's business or see
the executive of it or is he he's one of
the owners yep so hey - Frank dropped
out of high school and South Korea and
then they started and went on and got
more people in there yep that's a big
business yeah so look I think you you
know you're dealing with what I'm
worried about for my kids which is do
you want to climb the mountain or do you
want to run away from the mountain and
both are right I don't you know what I'm
not even gonna use run away from the
mountain ever again ever again it's back
to visit me in my process running away
seems like a negative it's appropriate I
would [ __ ] him if I was my own son I
would [ __ ] not do anything close to
what I was I would try to become the
biggest artist in the world because I
wouldn't have wanted like it would have
been like [ __ ] it's daunting because I
want my own path that's who I am I just
know you know with the same chemicals I
have I would have wanted my own path you
know so look man if it's that real it
sounds like it's super real you need to
try to figure out what makes you tick
and it's very cliche for kids to have
very opposite reactions to very
significant parents success you either
want to go crazy and build a [ __ ]
empire by you know or you want to go
save the world or give it all back or
you know not be not play the same score
I think that's what their problem is
I have zero central Rangers right now
and I I think you have a lot bro I think
the fact that you're even using the
terminologies and I actually think you I
think you are early in the process but I
think the fact that you even know what
self-awareness is is a good starting
point lack of self-awareness is not even
acknowledging its existence you know you
don't know yourself yet that's but that
makes sense you know most of us didn't
so it's okay to not know what I'm gonna
do with my degree after you a hundred
percent brother it's preferable can you
like get hired by anyone yeah a hundred
percent my preference would be that you
do get hired somewhere where it still
gives you free time to get to know
yourself to you also do understand if
you're doing it for yourself
or if you're doing it for them look if
you're getting hired because you think
that's what your parents want you need
to get to that place first as long as
you're willing to live without them
supporting you financially well then
you're off to the races
that's the leverage for me my end point
is my family said yeah we're proud of
them I get it
it's very cultural like for India and
Russia and like Asia you know if you're
brown Asian or Eastern European you
we're all dip slight little versions of
the same [ __ ] so I've always been very
empathetic to it let me give you some
really good advice making your parents
proud on their terms in the short term
often leads to a very bad relationship
in the long term and those years hurt so
little pain in the beginning is a lot
better than a ton of pain at the end
and that's easy to say when you're not
in it like I am but it's the truth
especially however when me and my dad
but he's the one supporting everything
me financially a lot old school yeah get
it you're communicating through your mom
I know because because most there's only
the reason I'm always good at this stuff
is there's only eighteen to forty four
things in life life's basic I just know
I also lived it that's exactly what
happened with me and my dad luckily I
work directly for him and with him and
over time we got there but that would
have been my life that is excuse me that
is my brother's life that is my sister's
life I used to like I'm very close to
him but but what I did and what I would
recommend to you is to have the leverage
so they actually my answer of the
leverage is not to be not to be held
accountable to his finances College is
one thing he wanted that right but the
day you end is the day you don't take
another dollar it's 100 percent right
self-reliance you can't allow it
otherwise the relationship is skewed and
let me promise you one thing that is
going to garner more respect than
anything you'll ever do especially if
your dad wants you to take it because
the other thing with old school dads is
they want you to take it because they
like using it as leverage as long as
you're taking it then he can make you do
what he wants good to do this good what
do you want to do that's you're off
you're in a better place than most then
here then then you need to be in a place
where you don't take the money you get
in that place you'll win that's the
right advice I mean and that's why kids
pissed me off like I do a lot of content
for the kids and they love me but then
when I get one-on-one
I'm like you're a piece of [ __ ] you want
the money but don't want to listen to
your parents they're paying for the
right to tell you what to do get off the
payroll and you're such a big-shot your
startup [ __ ] like this you can't have
both you can't have the [ __ ] Mercedes
and the [ __ ] gym membership that your
parents are paying for but then do it
exactly how you want spitting in their
face against what they want right so
either you you're your own person or
you're not it's binary I love when
people like it's so fun for me like just
sitting here I don't want to leave like
all these meetings and emails and DMS
and conversations I have like your arm
independent well they do paper - Jim oh
and I do have an Amazon stipend yeah an
uber is on my dad's credit card look
you're on the payroll you're on the
[ __ ] payroll get off the payroll and
do it oh [ __ ] you want stay on the
payroll and do whatever the [ __ ] they
want
[Music]